こんにちははじめ社長ですというわけで今仲が家にいることが皆さん多いと思うんです
けどもというわけで家にいてもできるすぐ簡単で楽しいことがあるのでちょっと皆さん
に紹介しようと思いますみなさん youtube の動画でですねぼくピザ屋さんと
か誰かに録音した音声だけで通話できるのとか電話できるのっていう企画あるじゃない
ですか
それです
ヤスがしろと言ってるわけじゃないんですそれの動画がちょっと結構多いんですよね
ただ頭でに録音してはいとかいいえとか
わかりましたありがとうございましたっていう音声を録音して膝とか何か注文するとき
にその音声だけでどこまで電話の1と2ができるのかというのはアレですけどもそれは
左岸でにとりましてなら北ガーターも6をしたような音声で誰かと電話しますとはいと
いいえとがある
がとうございます基本的なことだけを絞って誰かにゃん電話しますとそうするとたぶん
その同じようなことを繰り返したり音が無機質な声とかで会話してると
録音した音声で電話したんぜんって思うと思うんですよそんな勝ち録音した音声風に
電話したら
録音した音声で喋ってるでしょって言われる説
ああああああ
これは皆さん党も脱にもできるのでぜひやってみてくださいとだけでこれですねすごい
シンプルであの僕は本当にあたかも録音したような音声でしゃべるだけ同じようなこと
をそれでその電話相手が露光さを添えてしゃべってんじゃんって思わせたらもうかつ
ですね早速ちょっと言葉だけ決めていきましょうか
晩まで六甲した人間っぽく行きたいんでちょっとしゃべることができるか考えてみます
プップッ
ピッ
というわけで僕がされることが決まりましたというで今日お元気ですかはいいいえ
確かにそんなことあるよの条理ですねバカ言うな27の太いこの10個だけで電話して
僕がすごい録音さような感じを出すんで前は相手がろ今でしょ
言わせます必ずや早速ターゲット電話してみましょう
では村井さんに電話しても無駄に散歩引っかかって品じゃよ
大下こんにちははいお疲れさんですどうしました
元気ですかフレキスよ
確かに
はいめちゃいいですよ私はいつもいいんですよ
ばっか言うないやちょっとはじめたちはもう私は気づきましたよ
はいこれのごんろくんだったでしょうわぁ
ブーバーすごいこんなにすべくぐるとぱふぇんだを作るまでー
音ですね笑さあ今のですね
電話
ロックオンのを音声では
ありません
嘘や空けず普通に僕がそれっぽく喋っていただけるね
0でいますよね
ホテルあるぞ米を作るのです
いいオレこれこれすごいねちょっと待ってこれぜひかかるぞおれオレ才能あれかこれ
ロボットボイスの達人かもしんねこれこれはひょっとしたら
を醸しましたこんにちは
ポリッシュは元気ですか
ケーキです
そんなことある
そんなことあるよ
確かにへ
山なんだ
バカ言うななんだこれなんかボタン押して鳴らしてなかった大バッハ
ああああああ
100 u 2なりかけた100%そうもうこれすごいねこれみんな是非行ってみて
くれたこれ本当に引っかかるこれはやばいをつけたまで f 選出します
あの録音してた
音声ではありません
録音瀬田音声ぽっく喋ったらそう思われる雪2動画を説明すると全員引っかかれて全員
あんなんかボタンでこっちことしてるなーみたいな
それというわけでヒカキンさんも引っかかるということはこれもだれにでも引っかかる
ということですね
これすごいた本当もう一人ぐらいかけてもよくから
ん
こんにちは
今日は人気ですか
元気ですよ確かに
pash
はい
バカ言うな馬鹿は行ったラップ確かに大変そう
そんなことあるスラム来ないですよ確かにっ
そうですよね
範囲ぶっぱいあわああの
別に今は言えますけど普通
たしかにたしかいい知らないでしょ
岸できたからだ
はいはい
確かに出してい
しませんですか
いいえ
何ですか
バカ言うな何も言ったら
そんなことあるそうするとらしいでしょ
何にも言ってないでしょうねぇ
確かにん
2727だたしかにたしかにない何を確かただいま
そんなことある r ディション20話券は1枚んだといえば
バスがして言われないんですかまあ確かに何ですか27そんなことある
そんなことないよ色のだよいうかよの草履ですね
4日くりんだ謎20だんだん2周なったんだ
年齢
元気ですかいいです元気ですか
元気ですよ元気元気ですか元気ですよ+書いたんですよね
またいうなばギター確かに
えっ
5浴衣下がりましたよと草履ですね
4勝利だぞあー27なると後床下がるっていう
話そんなことあるいやあれじゃ今いい
兄えん違うんですね確かに
た試験じゃない電気ですかゲイじゃあなんでだよ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
頭おかしい人には通じなるかもしれないですねあ
保存何ですかよ全然じゃあなーなんだねぇ
すっ今ねー
よくあるじゃん編 youtube だの傷は誰のもと木と紙さーん
なんかボタンを競ってこそ録音した音声
[音楽]
思いましたよで話してませんえっ
橋ない録音した音声絵っぽくしゃべってたらそう思われる説っていうやつ
し思ってたよめっちゃ終わってなくは口に出さんかっただけが皆さんもぜひやっちゃい
ますよねよ